- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is just do it.
Over to you, J.J. Abrhams.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep be going
- Because the resources have
been so limited for so long,
there are a lot of people who would say,
god, if I only had
access to a camera I would make a movie.
There's a lot of talk about it.
I remember when I was in college,
I spent most of my time in
my room writing screenplays.
Really bad screenplays, but
I was in my room doing that,
when I probably should have
been studying or something.
There are a lot of people
I remember at parties
who would talk about writing
and that they want to be a writer.
But I would also notice that they were out
every time I happened to go out,
they would always be out
and I just know that their
people who talk about
what they'd do if,
but they're not actually doing anything.
And so, it's a lot easier actually,
to write a screenplay
than you think it is.
Might not be good,
but most people talk
about writing screenplays
but don't actually write them.
The people who write them,
you're already like in the top 10%,
because you've actually written it.
- To achieve your goal in business,
you need to think big and start small.
To achieve your goal in business,
Be the CEO and the janitor, both.
Too many entrepreneurs
just want to be the CEO,
just want to be the visionary,
just want to come up with all the ideas.
But you don't want to do any of the work
and you need both.
You need the vision,
you need the guidance,
you need the high level thinking,
but you need to do the work.
The janitor does the work.
And that's what so many
entrepreneurs are missing.
You just want to play in the big picture,
but you don't actually
want to get anything done.
And if that's you,
then your ideas going to die with you.
You're going to die this
really bitter old person,
who always had these big visionary ideas,
but never had the team to do it.
Never had the resources to do it.
Never had the support to do it
and whatever excuse you
want to throw out there.
But really, it's because you didn't want
to get down in the trenches
and clean the toilet.
You didn't want to do the grungy, grimey,
hustle daily, in and out work.
And at the start, you need to do the work.
Like, yes, as you get up,
as you build a team,
as you start having success,
you can move higher
and higher up the chain
and just be more of that visionary.
But at the start, when it's just you,
you got to do everything.
You got to hustle it out.
If I look at this YouTube channel,
I started doing everything.
In my first video,
I collabed with a friend of mine,
he helped me film it,
but most of my videos
at the start, were me.
Me with a camera, with no
lighting and no microphone
and sometimes it was wobbly
and the focus was out
and it was hard to see me.
Me doing the editing,
which was Windows Movie
Maker at the beginning.
Very basic, very simple, very plain.
Me doing the naming,
me doing the tagging,
me doing the promotion,
me doing the background research,
me doing the in front of the camera stuff,
me doing the audio recording.
Everything, me, it was
me, I did everything.
I planned everything from a CEO level
and then I did all the
work from a janitor level.
And as I built it up to the point
where I started making some money,
I started handing off some of those tasks.
And that let me go from a video a week,
to a video a day.
And I moved closer and closer
and closer up the chain
to the point where now
I'm guiding everything,
I'm still the on camera talent.
Right, I still do this
work 'cause I love it.
Not only because I'm good
at it and getting better,
but I love it.
This is what I love doing.
I still review every video that goes out
and all the research behind it,
'cause I love it, 'cause I learn from it.
'cause I care about the
product that we're creating.
But my team puts all that together.
You know, even this.
We use Evernote, oh let me load it up.
You know, I use Evernote here
and I got a list of all the topics
I need to talk about today.
All the topics, who I'm
doing shout outs for,
where the research is, what the clips is
that I need to watch.
All of that stuff, my
team puts together for me.
This thing gets filmed,
I have Jason behind the
camera filming it for me.
He's going to send it to
Christine, my video editor.
We've got three editors who
are going to cut it all up,
post to the YouTube channel, title it,
descriptions, tags, playlists,
all of that stuff that goes up.
And I'm guiding it from a high level.
But I built it up to that point.
If I was just starting out
and that was my idea.
Like, I'm going to do this
and I'm going to wait for other
people to do things for me,
it's not going to happen.
And so it's thinking big,
I love it, think big,
you need it, 'cause a lot of
people don't think big enough
and they stay stuck being a
janitor for their entire life.
Think big, it's great, but start.
Be the janitor too
and work your way up.
Add more value, focus on what
you can add the most value to,
so you can bring on people to alleviate
some of the tasks for you
and help you build closer to
that big thing you want to do.
To achieve your goal, you need
to think big and act small.
So question day today is,
I want an example task, from you guys,
your CEO task and a janitor task.
The big and the small.
Give one example of both that
you're currently doing today
in your business or plan to
do today in your business,
one CEO task, one janitor task.
Write in the comments below
and we'll join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kate Maree O'Brien.
Kate, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really
appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying it.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
Hey Believe Nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it,
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- Just do it, just pick up a camera
and start shooting something.
Don't wait to be asked
because nobody's going to ask you
and don't wait for the perfect conditions
because they'll never be perfect.
It's a little bit like having a child.
If you wait until the
right time to have a child,
you'll die childless.
And I think filmmaking is
very much the same thing,
you just have to take the plunge
and just start shooting something.
Even if it's bad, you can always hide it,
but you will learn something.
- It was a lot harder to get
started when I was growing up
and wanting to be a movie director,
almost at 12 years old
because when I first picked up a camera--
- Where were you living when you first--
- [Steven] Scottsdale.
- You were in Arizona?
- I was looking for a way
to fulfill the requirements
to get a photography merit badge.
I was in the Boy Scouts of America.
And--
- Did you want to be a filmmaker before?
- No, I didn't want to
be a filmmaker at all,
I just wanted to be an Eagle Scout.
That was my only aspiration,
I wanted to get the highest
rank I could in Scouting.
And so on my way to being an Eagle Scout,
I had to get a certain
requisite amount of merit badges
and one of them I wanted
to get was photography.
And a requirement was,
to tell a story with still photographs.
And my Dad's camera broke,
he did not have a still camera,
like the Brownie Kodak that
he had, wasn't working.
But he did have an 8mm
Kodak, 8mm movie camera
and I went to the Scout Master
and I said, can we change the rules,
just so I can tell a story on film?
Because we don't have a still camera.
And the Scout Master
said, go ahead and do it.
So, I got three minutes worth of film,
which is, by the way, all
those cameras used to take
these little three minute rolls of film.
And I made this Western on a weekend--
- How did you edit?
Did you camera cut?
- In camera cut.
You know a little shot,
my friends in cowboy outfits
robbing a stagecoach,
which was sort of an
exhibit outside of place
called Pinnacle Peak Patio.
A restaurant which is still
there, outside of Scottsdale.
- How did you know to camera cut?
- I just figured, you know,
you do a shot in this direction,
the bad guys with their guns and masks on,
my sisters played the damsels in distress
in the stagecoach, giving
away their costume jewelry,
well, my mother's jewelry.
(laughing)
I didn't tell we took my Mom's jewelry,
to give away to 12 year olds,
you know, pretending to be robbers.
And I made this little movie
and then showed it to the
Boy Scouts troop that weekend
and they all went crazy for it.
They screamed and applauded.
I suddenly got bitten by that bug
and I wanted to do this
for the rest of my life.
It was like, became so clear to me.
But it was hard then
because to make movies,
you had to pay for film, pay
for developing of the film.
So, I had to go to my Dad to say,
Dad, I'll earn some money
but I can't earn all the money,
'cause I have to go to school.
I can't get a job to earn the money
to pay for all this equipment.
So my Dad helped me.
However, today it's easier.
Today, everybody seems
to have a camcorder.
Everybody has some high digital camera
and it's a lot easier
to get your hands on--
- You can buy that editing
program for the computer.
- You can buy a software
program for the computer
and go out and make a movie
and tell a story and figure out
who you are as a storyteller.
And so in a sense, it's easier today
for young people to at
least prove to themselves
what they want to do for
the rest of their lives
or at least in the interim
of the rest of their lives.
And it's also, if you
get bitten by that bug,
you can make a lot of little movies
and some how, those films will get seen
by people, hopefully, that will hire you
to do a music video someday,
or a tv commercial or a television show,
or someday, a feature film.
- I was very headstrong young person
and by 1983 or 4,
had started my own publishing company,
to publish my own books.
Realizing that no one else will publish me
and I was right about that.
And so my first book, I saved
my food money from Black Flag,
a little here, a little there,
and I saved up enough to
make a fold and staple book.
I couldn't type, so I
hand wrote out the things
and I made a dummy that I could
offset, print, fold, and staple.
And I sold them for $2.
Mainly gave them away, but I sold enough,
and they blew out, 500 just went.
And then I took that money to
make another print run of that
and from that money,
I made my first paperback
and 33 years later, that's
a fully staffed company
with books in translation
and hardcover editions
and the whole nine yards.
But it started with, I'm
going to do my thing.
I'll be City Lights
Junior, without the talent.
I did that at the same time
as I was doing my first spokenword gigs
and why did I have the
gumption and the audacity
to start my own book company?
Because I come from punk rock.
I come from watching Ian
MacKaye invent Dischord Records,
on his Mom's kitchen table.
I come from folding and gluing
picture sleeves together.
Black Flag had their own label,
of course you'd do it yourself.
You want to make a book?
Sit down and write it,
then go to the printing place.
Where's the printer?
Get the phonebook and find a printer.
We make records, make some books.
You just do it.
It's like you don't even think about it,
you just do it.
I'm sure that writing is just awful,
but I did it.
And without even hesitation,
I'm making my own book companies.
Stop me, I dare you.
I never thought about it twice.
Just because DIY, man.
Like, let your voice be heard.